à Zarzis au sud de la Tunisie les jours
se répète inlassablement pour ces
naufragés dans les espoirs de rejoindre
les côtes européenne s'amenuise au fil
des jours et berger dans des foyers mis
en place par le commissariat des Nations
Unies pour les réfugiés au encore le
Croissant-Rouge tunisien ils peuvent
parfois attendre des mois avant d'être 6
et ils sont marocains égyptiens malien
encore 20 galets et tous ont décidé de
quitter leur pays au péril de leur vie
en quête d'un avenir meilleur
Moussa a 22 ans partie du Maroc il y a
un mois il a traversé l'Algérie avant de
te retrouver chez un passeur qu'il a dû
payer 5000 € pour la promesse d'une vie
joint de la misère et du désespoir mais
le rêve à très vite virer au cauchemars
la nuit du 22 novembre dernier
quand
on était de 4 m on a voulu faire
demi-tour pour repartir à l'aube sur le
retour le bateau a commencé à prendre
l'eau au frais à couler du Nil
des
4 jours dans l'eau sans boire ni manger
ni rien du tout
acheter débarquement Matisse
Boubacar faisait partie aussi je sais
clandestin depuis sa ville natale de
teralithe au nord-est de Tombouctou le
jeune Malien dû traverser l'Algérie pour
arriver en Libye dans l'espoir de
trouver un pas de sœur pour l'Italie
il y a la violence
de peur d'être reconnu
moi je dis que à mon frère donc on n'a
pas reçu le dire peut-être si on a
beaucoup d'argent on allait sortir mais
si on a pas beaucoup d'argent on allait
mourir c'est que Moussa Booba qui a de
la chance ce soir-là sain et sauf il a
pu être placée dans un foyer pour
migrants en attendant la suite des
événements les autres n'ont pas eu cette
chance chaque année et les courants
marins sont échoués des milliers de
corps sur les côtes tunisienne dans ce
cimetière imaginé par un artiste
tunisien l'ai mise en terre sont devenus
le quotidien des bénévoles et des
membres des organisations
internationales et un nombre
impressionnant dans le corps qui qui est
rejetée donc par la mer et qui sont
enterrés ils dorment ici donc les
manière définitive et donc de temps bien
sûr individuelle nous avons aussi des
prélèvements de l'ADN qui peut nous
faciliter sa technique peut faciliter
justement la reconnaissance éventuelle
du corps et le remettre à sa famille
voilà là je vous rends triste c'est une
image qui m'a marqué on en fait j'étais
présent la quand la protection civile as
trouvé cette femme qui tenait à coller
carrément son bébé à côté d'elle et qui
éventuellement vous voulez le sauver
mais malheureusement ils sont décédés
tous les deux là vous voyez le bébé et
la maman qui qui sont ici ça ça ça m'a
marqué ça c'est une trace que je veux
pas oublier tout tout à fait une
situation qui a pris de l'ampleur ces
dernières années accentuer pas la guerre
en Libye et la crise sanitaire du coup
pour le docteur cymes la Tunisie ne
pourra pas gérer cette histoire il
appelle Union européenne à prendre ses
responsabilités dans ce drame
Tunisie passe en ce moment par une crise
économique assez dur et ce qui fait que
le gouvernement est l'état tunisien
n'est pas en possibilité de faire le
plus un de ce qu'il fait en ce moment
j'espère que l'Europe aussi se
réveillera et que il doit penser que si
cette personne oubien doivent rester
chez eux et donc faire une aide
substantielles pour que ces gens alors
fais ça c'est un point essentiel ou bien
aussi porter secours à ces gens que
lorsque j'arrive accidentellement chez
nous
selon le Haut-Commissariat des Nations
Unies pour les réfugiés depuis le début
de l'année plus de 58 migrants en plus
atteindre les côtes italiennes alors que
près de 1300 exilé ont trouvé la mort en
pleine Méditerranée